film roots he would say allah he was
calling on god invited the creator of
allah yeah that's the beautiful thing
about islam and islam just means to
submit your will to that one creator
that one god and that's the wonderful
thing you know when malcolm
when when muhammad ali when they went
back to their roots and they went back
and they started digging
they came to islam because they saw what
you're talking about that all the
prophets remember this right
the
when malcolm went yeah to
mecca right yes yes yes
so you know
yeah it messed his head up right because
he never
seen someone yell color
or this man color that's feminine or
that man colored that all got along
exactly that's different races where it
lets you know
at the end of the day god is love
love is peace
and when people can understand that
that's when this world will get better
where you can show your kids how much do
you love how much do you know about
islam have you liked looking into
malcolm
i have i have read every bible
have you read the quran yes yeah yeah
what was the main message you got from
it
just like the holy bible the whole thing
is
everything is love do you believe jesus
was god or sent by god because we use
jesus we believe he's a mighty messenger
and we love i believe that jesus
which is god's son
how can i say this in the correct way
he's another prophet and what i mean by
another prophet there you go
there's no one higher than
the lord you feel me that's the almighty
the creator that happens on earth is
that that's the one all praises and
things and worship belong to the
creators
you know his
son was a a prophet to show everybody
something now when you say son what we
would just say we would just make an
adjustment we would say obviously he's
closer to god than any of us
metaphorically would say that we're all
the children of god but god doesn't have
sons and daughters you know literally
that's right right right right and i
agree with that there you go you mind if
i if i just take one minute i'll give
you a real quick run down what islam so
you just have a real comprehensive easy
to understand
we believe that islam was there since
day one with the first man adam and
throughout time god almighty out of his
love like it's about love out of his
love and mercy he sent guidance and
every messenger came with the same
message every prophet of messenger came
to the same message thank you that's
what i was trying to make you party
like i'm christian but
god sent every
message
in different religion god almighty sent
messengers and prophets different places
at times and destinations and from there
that message is always the same worship
the creator that happens on earth alone
without associates and obey the
messenger that was sent so at noah's
time you have to obey just like how you
guys say allah to allah
like like how we say all love to jesus
what i've seen over the years talking to
many christians also is because
obviously they don't know that we also
as muslims love and revere jesus as one
of the mightiest messengers sent by god
that he was the messiah over time god
almighty sent message prophecy message
all came to the same message worship one
and only one god and be morally upright
so the messenger that was set during
that time thank you you see how you said
it during that time
every every one
then we say prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him thank you my
brothers thank you you see so during
jesus time we would say that the message
was
what that means is there's nothing you'd
have to proclaim or profess that there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
creator that heavens and earth and jesus
is his messenger yes during moses
is nothing worthy worship except the one
god almighty and moses messenger we say
during this time now
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the one god and muhammad is his final
messenger right so jesus did pro certain
miracles to prove that he was indeed a
messenger sent by god you see how you
asked me yeah have i ever read the quran
that's the living miracle that we have
today
what's the last message in the quran
prophet muhammad peace and blessings
yes thank you my brother you know
malcolm when he came back
from hajj you know when he's standing
come over here he's standing like sure
he's standing next to the white to the
black that's how malcolm's
before i went to the nation
yes of the holy land
i never knew
i had brothers that was white look at
that asian
black
or air right yes
because his mind was
washed with
anybody that had pale skin and blue eyes
or blonde hair or looked like a white
man was an enemy but you're not your
enemy no you're your own enemy because
guess what if you don't believe in the
lord
you make yourself the enemy people can
do stuff
but
you can forgive them
forgiveness is the biggest thing in this
world and i wish a lot of people would
understand that are you feminists
forget people